two days ago this man came on the show
and he said he needed a hug
now he's the one giving out hugs and
hugging everybody
from men and blazers we had to get roger
bennett back here on the show
and he's back here on this show how are
you roger oh
it's a great day to be alive rich it
really is do you hear the people sing
singing a song of angry men holy crap
what have we just lived through together
rich in the past
48 hours today roll from horror
stupid vacation darkness
to joy collective wonder and a
just rising up fans rising up to protect
everything that we love you look at this
super league and i'm sure right now
there's planes of
super league merch t-shirts caps with
the logo on
flying off to a country where you know
that everyone's wearing
new england patriots undefeated season
t-shirts right now
xfl quibby fire festival
ben askren they all lasted longer than
it is and it's bloody wonderful
what if i told you before we hung up
that the next you're going to come back
in two days
and you're going to be introduced by a
john henry apology video
saying little things i mean please was
that john henry or was that freedom
called the only
comms team after betraying
michael and then just trying desperately
to be like yeah i know i did that
thing but i'm sorry i mean it's um
i hit all i know is i don't know if it's
locked down
or you know in lockdown football
which we've always said is the
most important least important thing
sports in general
maybe we've always known its place but
it's become so immense
just a sense of global connection when
an incredible goal is good you know you
are connecting to people all over the
world the narrative the nourishment the
meaning
i will say yesterday
chelsea football club were about to play
they were one of the six
teams that were breaking away gonna form
their own super european
super league and the chelsea fans
stormed their own stadium milling around
preventing their own team who they love
they love that team they prevented their
own team's birth from reaching that
stadium
but storming around chanting six greedy
bastards you've ruined our game
with banners that had noticeably dollar
signs on them
not euros you know they were aiming this
at the premier league owners who
happened to be american the leaders the
cronkies
the glazes of tampa bay john henry of
the boston red sox it was very clear to
them that it was the american industry
without the heart of it all
and then news broke news broke that
chelsea were going to be the first club
to pull out within 48 hours
and a rule went up on those streets rich
a rule
a joyous rule and i can't tell you how
much pleasure how much i'm shocked
by how dark this has been for me
personally and i'm shocked by how giddy
how delighted how many beers were
smashed open
uh yesterday afternoon and it's uh it's
a remarkable thing to relive with it
roger bennett men and blazers co-host at
raj bennett on twitter here on the rich
eisen show i guess the only
analogy because you know as as you know
we hear um in this country we do not
commu
compute okay we do not compute that fans
say
no and billionaire class ownership says
okay
and um i guess the only equivalent
wasn't just to use i guess the stan
kroenke equivalent is that rams move
from saint louis
to los angeles fans in st louis saying
no
but the fans in los angeles say welcome
and we all move on
it just seems that basically the fan
base was being left behind
and there was no relocation physical
relocation just relocation
in terms of the construct the pyramid as
they use it
the phrase in in football um in europe
and and that's where the conundrum was
maybe for these american owners that you
still
need the fans you still need that and
how i guess that's was that the
reckoning is that is that an appropriate
way to put it here
i i i i i do find you know i
love american sports the great day of my
life becoming an american i adore it
it was chicago bears winning the super
bowl that super bowl winning team that
changed that
the course of my life made me dream of
moving to the city that william
refrigerator perry and walter payton
were storming around
i love you know the white sox i love
american sports as much as anybody but
i've never quite
understood the compliance of american
fans of yeah just lift my team up yeah
i'll sling it around
and just say louis you just you just
suffer in silence because we don't want
to hear your move you're moaning with a
los angeles
rams now i i've never understood how
that occurs and i'd say so
one of the shocking things and
ultimately the fatal mistake is these
owners
announced that they were doing this jp
morgan were backing this a fortune was
to be made
they instantly lost every stakeholder in
the game not just the fans who will get
to in a minute the media obviously but
club legends
managers their own players spoke out
that's it it would be like the rams
leaving in the player saying hold on a
minute
we don't do this former players
broadcasters
the government even the royal bloody
family rich spoke out about this
and the fatal mistake and i'm fascinated
by this this is the story
still to be told having spoken to a
couple of owners
in europe they planned this they thought
about this they had
a phalanx of lobbyists and government
boys pr
specialists they had bought whole
ukrainian bot forms to barrage
across social media why the super league
was such a wonderful idea it's quite
funny to look at those tweets on twitter
on social media now but of all the
complex scenarios
that they plan for the possibility
of their own fans it was that their own
fans turned against them
clearly never crossed their mind they
thought
the only challenges would come from
supporters of other clubs
the lesser clubs the unsuper clubs
you've been left behind to liverpool
there's another team in liverpool
evident that the mets of liverpool
happened to support them my whole life
they thought the everton fans would be
up in arms and they'd be able to laugh
at them
and say that that was just that was just
envy
what they didn't bank on was liverpool
fans
rising up and saying no that the club
that's not what they stood for they
wouldn't be
leaving the history behind the memory
the traditions and it was really a
historic misread rich perhaps the
biggest
in global football club history the
english football fans they didn't know
their own
fans are tribal passionate devoted and
how
deeply the clubs are built into the
fabric of the city they're not after
thoughts
their fans are not customers the games
are not just content
and the american owners have tried to
treat english fans as if they're just
extras in the background of their movie
and they weren't having it
the author of the forthcoming memoir
reborn in the usa in english
in englishman's love letter to his
chosen home roger bennett here on the
rich eisen show
so what next what's the aftermath i mean
because we were joking yesterday there's
gonna be like costanzan seinfeld just
showing up to work the next day like oh
hey everybody you know like
i mean what what does happen now it's
fascinating last night manchester city
who are owned um by a petro state
were the second team to uh to to walk
out
on the super league and the uefa the
governing body uefa incredibly corrupt
let's be clear there's no good guys in
this
there's no i mean this is like dr evil
and dr
evil up who are we really seeing fight
here
uh the ue for president issued an
instant statement saying i welcome city
back into the european football
family which is predictable but still
shocking because 24 hours earlier
manchester city were the defectors that
turn coats the devil
no greedy hell bent on destroying
football but because they jumped off the
sinking ship
they were being held as as heroes it's
as if no one's watched game of thrones
and and saw what happened to
littlefinger in the end
so you've got 14 unsuper teams in the
premier league they need to first of all
work out what they're going to do with
these six returning
uh kind of defang um elf
beaters who thought they were alphas and
they've got to work out how do they
punish them will it be a financial
punishment
will it be points taken off them which i
don't think it will be
but you can see um that
the spokespeople for the game your
charles barkley
of of english soccer yeah shaquille
o'neal is two of them there's a guy gary
neville who happens to be a manchester
united
legend and his statement last night he
said the glazes have no place left in
manchester anymore
the glazers have no place left in
manchester anymore is what he really
said
and uh you know the glazes are putting
out video they they put out statements
a very a poor one overnight that was not
well received that showed no contrition
a longer one that was clearly not
written by the glazes about an hour ago
and then the the shaquille o'neal of
english football jamie carrick
who happens to be a liverpool legend is
on the fa you know
it's a host of every big game he said i
don't
see a future for the ownership of fsg at
liverpool i really don't they're making
it worse for themselves
the longer they hang on and that's why
you get liverpool owner john henry
dropping the
apology video trying to take blame
solely on himself it wasn't anybody else
i've learned my lessons though i'm never
going to forget
and you know it's fascinating fsg i want
to say
this is what i don't understand and and
that this is the one piece i
need to know a lot more about is
they are owners who are deeply
sophisticated they are owners who
had to work so bloody hard to earn the
trust of liverpool fans in the first
place rich
i don't know if you remember but
liverpool were run by another pair of
american owners
hicks and gillette uh who ran the team
into bankruptcy and just utterly
um you know arrogant ignorant incredibly
destructive
american owners and fsg work so bloody
hard to earn the trust liverpool fans
they took them
on three years of unbelievable glory a
champions league win
and then you know this a team that were
great in the seventies and eighties
thirty-year title drought ended
delirious it's hard to believe
that it was less than a year ago all of
that good will
for it to be fritted away so quickly so
devastatingly
and so self-destructively bridging
taking that bridge between them and the
fans and just setting it away
it is it's it's totally befuddling
it it is i guess there the moral of the
story is don't
don't mess with the uh
the english soccer fan is what it seems
like that's the moral of the stories do
not
mess with the tradition
it doesn't matter so so uh what are you
gonna call
the uh the super team six from now on i
mean is that what they're called is that
the way it's going to be
it will not be forgotten it will
definitely not be forgotten
from liverpool liverpool and scout says
i want to make it clear
people have never been there it's an
incredibly beautiful city it's like the
baltimore of england
and we we are you know with
good talkers with dreamers but my god if
there are olympic medals handed out for
grudge holding
we would meddle every single olympics
we'd be like
yeah what china we don't forget
we don't forgive i said this to you on
um
whatever it got is it really only monday
two days ago roger
the world spins fast so i said to you
you don't
f with scouts as they will come to you
they will
come to boston and they will destroy and
you know that so that they won't be
forgotten
it really won't this there's a lot of
talk about changing the ownership
structure in england and whether the the
fan trust should be
given over the ship but there's also the
dark side that this is just the ewoks
winning the battle for endor and there's
a whole war ahead
and these you know we've just won this
battle but these issues
are going to rear again you wait for a
still deeply corrupt
i mean is tammany hall and slowly slowly
next year they'll get what they want
but just through so that everybody gets
their cuts i won't be clear this is not
this is not ultimate glory it's a
beautiful moment and i talked on our
podcast today
about the the poet eduardo galliano
incredible man you required
um poet who was obsessed with football
and he wrote something which i thought
about a lot
ultimately these owners have watched
empty stadium sports for the last year
and yet the broadcast rights have played
well
that they can sell the these games to
china they can sell these games to
asia they can sell you know in america
we've loved every second even though
there's no fans in the stadium fake
noise
and i think they made a fatal mistake in
galliano wrote
in one of his books football in time
of sun and shadow he wrote have you ever
entered an empty football stadium
and this could go for any american
american sports stadium too this is not
just football you know that
he said try it stand in the middle of
the field and listen
there's nothing less empty than an empty
stadium
there's nothing less mute than stan's
bereft of spectators
and that memory that deep connection
that emotional
feeling just that generational um
utter devotion to the team that is
ultimately what
the american owners i mean either forgot
or just had yes men around them who
didn't bring it up as a
i'd love to have been around that board
table rich when they're like this is
what we're gonna do
uh and not one single person you know
try to at least scenario change and be
like but what about the fans that is
that is perhaps the most staggering
element of this whole story roger
thanks for the time best to michael as
well to the uh the men and blazers
um and i guess we'll talk friday i mean
is that the way it can work we'll have
you back on friday
there could be a super duper league in
place by then who knows how football
works but i will say
god bless america and uh i'll be back
when america win the world cup next year
mate well now that you know we can have
pulisic play
you know he's eligible again for those
48 hours like dammit
oh my gosh the ewoks winning the battle
for endor rich
godspeed carriage same to you there's
roger bennett everybody
wow hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here